بايت
شيء اخر لكن الخلطه بينهما يشتت السياسي
ويبعده عن العمل الجاد الذي تحتاجه
بريطانيا حاليا هكذا وصف الانتقال المفاجئ
للنائب البريطاني والوزير السابق من
العالم السياسي الى عالم البرامج الواقعيه
ليشارك في برنامج ايام السلايبوتي
بالعمل السياسي
يقال ان مات هانكوك ربما يمر بازمه منتصف
العمر ففي مقر وزاره الصحه هذا عمل هانكو
من عام 2018 حتى عام 2021 ولكن بعد فضيحه
خلقه لقيود كورونا وتحت انتقادات من
عائلات ضحايا الوباء الطره للاصدقاء له
[موسيقى]
ذروه ازمه هانكو كانت بعد استلام ريش
السوناتا لمهامه حيث تجاهل الاخير هانكو
تماما وتفادي مصافحته في فيديو انتشر على
مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي محرج عنها
لكن مشاركه الوزير السابق في البرنامج
الواقعي لم تقلل من وقعه احراجه حيث
شاركوب في مسابقات اكل شامله تناول حشرات
واجزاء غريبه من لحوم الحيوانات وصفت
بالمقززه
كما واجه اسئله محرجه من المتسابقين
وتعليقات ساخرا هانت عليه في الصحف وعلى
مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي
هروب مات هانكوك من عالم السياسه الى
استراليا للمشاركه في برنامج الواقع لمرمم
صورته كما اراد لكن وصوله الى المراحل
النهائيه من المسابقه بتصفيه من الناس
يثير تساؤلات حول مدى قدرته على ضمان
مستقبلا افضل لمسيرته السياسيه لصباح
العربيه من لندن عروب عبد الحق